[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue non pas sur le plateau
d' interdit date est à dire mais chez
moi confinement oblige nous continuons
notre tour des pays présentés comme des
modèles dans leur gestion de l'épidémie
après l'allemagne et le maroc nous nous
intéressons aujourd'hui avec alain gras
qui est sociologue à la suède qui reste
le seul pays
ouvert aujourd'hui en europe et qui a
moins de morts que la france et puis
avec l'économiste christine assemblée
nous nous verrons le cas du portugal on
parle en effet de miracle portugais
alain gras bonjour vous êtes sociologues
des techniques professeur émérite à la
sorbonne
vous êtes un spécialiste de la suède où
vous avez vécu et enseigné vous êtes
l'auteur entre autres du livre la suède
et ses populations coécrit avec richard
s'auto alors la nacion avec 24 décès
pour 10 mille habitants fait mieux que
la france alors que tout est resté
ouvert y compris les écoles et les
frontières
comment l'analysez-vous d'abord il ya
plusieurs manières d'analyser la manière
la plus commune c'est de dire que c'est
à cause de l'économie pour protéger
l'économie parce qu'ils n'avaient pas
assez d'hôpitaux après la passe et deux
lits dans les hôpitaux en suède ce qui
est tout ce qui est vrai mais ce qui est
vrai en général et qui n'est pas
particulièrement pour le pour le coc
vide sur vidéo qui emmenèrent une
technologie très haut niveau très élevé
donc je pense qu'il faut prendre des des
causes qui sont beaucoup plus profondes
et beaucoup plus anciennes qui sont sous
jacente et qui sont dans la culture
suédoise en particulier la culture
luthérienne qui est un élément très
important de la responsabilité de chaque
individu lutter vous savez c'était le
libre examen et c'est en fait une
responsabilité propre qui est demandé à
chaque individu temps le luthéranisme et
par les trois pays où ça réussit le
mieux les quatre c'est toute la
scandinavie c'est pas seulement la suède
c'est aussi les trois pays lui dit rien
et tant que je pense que cette religion
cette culture là
est un élément très important pour
recevoir la responsabilité personnelle
de chaque individu
le cas de la suède pour l'explorer un
peu plus en détail les cafés les
restaurants des cinémas et des salles de
sport continue de fonctionner les mêmes
seuls les événements publics de plus de
50% de plus de 50 personnes ne peuvent
avoir lieu
et encore ainsi à un rassemblement
spontané je crois que la police
n'intervienne pas non pas du tout alors
justement à satiété le grand débat vous
m'avez posé la question j'ai répondu une
manière un petit peu socio historique
mais il y a eu un rapport en 2018
ça s'appelle l'instinct ce que vous
faites et du trading
c'est un rapport qui est demandé par
l'état quand il peut faire une loi c'est
pas comme en france quand on fait une
loi on réfléchit un peu à bord bon donc
ce rapport qui est de plus de 400 pages
de 2018 et 7 7 7 ce rapport s'appelle
situera au plaid à m me smith lite
c'est à dire m tilly pardon mais til
it's ça veut dire gouverner et diriger
ou gouverner conduire avec confiance et
dans ce rapport vous avez exactement ce
qui a été fait maintenant où ils font la
balance entre ce qui est donné la
confiance aux individus leur faire
confiance
jusqu'au bout et même s'il y a des abus
les laisser aller jusqu'au bout de leurs
convictions et de leurs responsabilités
en enlevant contrebalancer avec la
possibilité du contrôle policier
c'est à dire qu'il ya les deux parties
en examen des deux situations la
situation où on les laisse avec leurs
responsabilités locales et personnels et
bien dans ce cas là le rapporteur fait
le calcul que finalement y aura beaucoup
moins de dégâts beaucoup moins de
difficultés après à gérer la situation
que si on fait un contrôle policier
un contrôle sévère des populations avec
des obligations qui entraînera une
certaine disons volonté de criminalité
ou en tout cas de délit aujourd'hui on
souhaitait depuis le début de
de la maladie il est recommandé de
respecter une distance de 2 mètres en
suède entre les entre les gens mais on
dit souvent que les suédois de toute
façon naturellement mêle des distances
plus grandes que nous on dit même que
les rares que les parents brasseur
enfants alors qu'en est il exactement
non non ça c'est tout à fait exagéré
c'est vrai que les démonstrations sont
pas les mêmes mais il n'empêche qu'il ya
eu quand même une transmission de la
culture l'acquis de la culture suédoise
et maintenant on s'embrasse gramasa se
dit en suédois et on s'embrasse on se
fait des bises comme les comme chez nous
pas autant je le reconnais mais on se
serre la main c'est c'est tout à fait
non ce n'est pas évidemment aussi
exubérante que je sais que dans les pays
latins mais la réalité que quand même
elle est à 7 assez proche de chez nous
c'est tout ce je ne sais pas ce pas
décisif incident ne sais pas c'est pas
la culture japonaise je veux dire c'est
pas la culture japonaise bien entendu on
a recommandé aux plus de 70 ans de
cesser de voir du monde mais mais là
aussi c'est pas la police qu'il fait
respecter un comme vous l'avez dit en
fait l'état fait confiance à sa
population
mais à l inverse la population fait
confiance à l'état et aux autorités
sanitaires
ah oui alors là là là c'est la grande
différence avec notre pays c'est que les
statistiques précédentes avant le corona
de donner 70% de pop et de la population
turque est d'accord avec les mesures
gouvernementales pour dans différents
domaines
j'ai maintenant avec le co ville c'est
pareil c'est même un peu plus haut de
70% dans l'étude qui avait été fait
auparavant avant le cornac et comparer
avec situation dans les pays européens
et même les états unis dans ces pays là
c'est 35% en général l'appui au
gouvernement
ensuite c'est 70% c'était 70% par le
corona et c'est toujours 70% avec le
corner vous parliez des autres pays
scandinaves qui sont également luthérien
disiez vous
mais le la suède a néanmoins plus de
plus de morts que la proportion égale
toujours un que la norvège que le
danemark ou la finlande
oui effectivement dont tu ne pars elle a
effectivement plus de morts mais d'autre
part on peut voir que la courbe suisse
elle exactement est parallèle à celle de
la suède du danemark pendant de la
norvège et la finlande
c'est à dire qu'elle est au dessus mais
le pic est passé et ça redescend
maintenant exactement au même moment que
dans les autres pays scandinaves
elle ça c'est ça c'est un fait établi
lors d'autre part j'ai des statistiques
très très récente d'aujourd'hui sur les
2400 et quelques quelques morts acte 1
2194 vous avez vous avez presque 1400
personnes qui sont des personnes âgées
de plus de 80 ans dans 800 qui ont pu 90
enfin c'est donc voyez une très grosse
proportion est dans ce qui reste
il y a il faut le reconnaître beaucoup
d'immigrés ces populations pauvres c'est
pas parce qu'ils sont immigrés c'est pas
ce sont des populations pauvres qui
n'ont s'ils n'ont pas la culture
luthérienne et à qui il faut expliquer
les choses et par exemple à stockholm
vous avez actuellement des panneaux qui
exquis et killer qui leur explique ce
qu'il faut faire qui leur donne
justement les mesures de barrières les
deux mètres 7 craquer explique tout cela
en perse pour personne à bien en un
arabe et même un espagnol en français
par contre est passé dix minutes mais
mais vous voyez donc il y a une volonté
pour faire participer les immigrés à ces
ascètes cette confrontation drame
mais évidemment que la culture leur
culture n'est pas la même et que donc
salir à un peu plus fragiles et puis
aussi ils ont des fragilités inhérentes
ils sont souvent plus faibles ils ont à
dire des conditions difficiles pour
venir jusqu'en suède et c'est donc en
fait le 2e le co vide le corona 510 on
est plus dangereux pour ses populations
de même qu'il est plus
pour les populations âgées alors
justement pour la population âgée ces
jus effectivement on dit que l'âge moyen
des décès en suède et de 81 ans et
qu'ils ont su lieu surtout dans les
maisons de retraite le gouvernement
d'ailleurs estime que c'est un échec
c'est l'échec de cette de sa lutte
contre la propagation mais en même temps
on sent bien que chez les suédois ils se
disent que ces gens là serait sans doute
mort de toute façon une espèce de
fatalisme dans ce domaine
oui oui sans doute effectivement de
toute manière dans sa disons je pas dit
je ne dis pas qu'ils avaient peur de la
mort en suède mais ou en scandinavie
mais c'est une réalité à laquelle on
sait faire face peut-être plus que chez
nous je sais pas pourquoi il y à une
fatalité
pourtant c'est pas dans lors de la
réunion du terrain en sommes enfin une
fatalité qui est par rapport à la mort
qui est beaucoup plus présente que chez
nous toujours est il que on a entendu
notre premier ministre à nous et douars
fils il peut dire qu'il fallait
apprendre à vivre avec la maladie et on
a l'impression que c'est exactement ce
qu'ont fait les suédois sauf qu'ils en
ont tiré d'autres conséquences
apprendre à vivre avec la maladie pour
eux est la seule façon durable
c'était justement de ne pas confiné et
de se responsabiliser les uns les autres
de demander aux personnes âgées aux
personnes à risque elle de prendre leurs
distances de rester chez elles mais à la
population de continuer de vivre en
respectant les gestes barrière c'était
ça finalement apprendre à vivre avec la
maladie
et c'est peut-être que voilà nous allons
devoir faire à notre tour une fois qu'on
va des confiné en france voilà mais le
problème est ce qu'on arrivera à nous
responsabiliser
est-ce qu est-ce qu on pourra se dire
c'est notre responsabilité de suivre les
les demandes du gouvernement parce que
justement en suède celui qui s'est
occupé de ces mesures de prendre ces
mesures afin qu'il a justifié ces
mesures
c'est en fait le responsable du service
épidémiologie de l' agence de sécurité
quand je dis à jean sécurité sanitaire
c'est pas ça en suède doit ces agences
de santé publique de santé du peuple
et c est lui le directeur de 1
à steinen qui est directeur du service
d'épidémiologie c'est lui qui a tout
pris c'est lui qui a dit il faut faire
ça il faut garder il faut votre il faut
pas faire de confinement je prends mes
responsabilités et c'est lui qui s'est
mis en avant et papa le gouvernement le
maintenant à laisser faire comme nous
évidemment il a consulté des experts
mais que le premier ministre et les
jamais apparu presque la muse la santé
on la connaît à peine
mais ces deux formes de gouvernement qui
sont totalement différentes de la nôtre
mais là aussi ça implique il a beau dire
je prends la responsabilité
ce monsieur on imagine en france que ça
aurait donné là aussi une question de
confiance de confiance dans une autorité
quelle qu'elle soit la grande-bretagne
et la hollande
au départ deux pays protestants
d'ailleurs mais pas le terrien avait
imaginé aussi de chercher l'immunité mme
groupe
c'est ça le but de l'as de la suède ils
ont craqué très vite pression des
autorités scientifiques pression des
médias
ils ont regardé chez les voisins ils
sont dit non on peut pas prendre le
risque
les suédois ont tenu bon et comment vous
expliquez ça il faut une sacrée une
sacrée autodétermination je pense que
c'est relié véritablement à leur
histoire vous savez il ya des
temporalités quant à chris fait
ressortir des temporalités différentes
et il a justement à l'ultra nice mais il
ya aussi des lits king
il ya aussi ce qu'on appelle le tignes
c'est à dire de toutes les deux toutes
les décisions étaient prises dans des
assemblées locales et on disait même le
roi même les nobles sont soumis à ces
décisions
donc c'est une c'est une vieille coutume
démocratique et et le rapport dont je
parle justement insisté sur la nécessité
de respecter la démocratie qu'ils de
l'ancien temps suédois et pas seulement
de la modernité et il ne faut pas avoir
peur d'être seul à faire ce que l'on
fait quand la moitié de la population
est confine à des degrés divers mais
confine restait le seul pays ouvert
c'est quand même sacrément que le thé
est oui alors là justement j'ai une
autre étude
l'américaine sur eux sur la vision aux
valeurs de liberté individuelle est au
sommet au sommet vous avez la suède plus
que le danemark et la norvège encore et
là je pense que c'est le tri liés à cet
aspect là je suis je suis libre de ma
décision je suis libre d'examiner la
décision qui m'a été proposé et si
j'adhère j'adhère jusqu'au bout quelle
crise est très étonnant parce que
halladay la scandinavie c'est vrai que
là que la suède est quand même bien
protégés par le danemark des frontières
qui lui allait conduire avec le
continent
d'un côté il ya la finlande que la
frontière avec la russie je dois dire
qu'il ya aussi il est aussi dans le
temps histoire suédoise des choses qui
ce qui les distingue des autres pays
c'est que la suède se battent s'était
toujours battu avec la russie c'était
cet ennemi principal et en 1900 en 1810
est arrivé bernadotte qui a dit ça
suffit maintenant on laisse tomber et en
laisse tomber la finlande qui avait été
pris par les russes et puis autre après
la semaine
elle n'a plus participé à aucune guerre
aucune 1,14 allemande essayer de la
faire venir ils ont pas voulu
épuisant a été neutre alors que l'on
peut n'ont pas été les autres pays
scandinaves
de la même manière on s'inquiétait en ce
qui concernait la suède qui
choisissaient de ne pas confiné on fasse
dire il va y avoir un pic terrible et
les hôpitaux vont être surchargé
or ça n'a pas eu lieu semble-t-il il ya
encore vingt pour cent des lits de
réanimation qui sont inoccupés à on
souhaite encore comment l'expliquez vous
mais là aussi c'est vraiment étonnant
alors ça j'avoue que je de chez guère
d'explications sinon justement le fait
que vendre ça on ne s'attendait à une
avalanche de corona qui entraînerait
d'intimidation respirateur et c est ça
ne s'est pas produit donc je pense que
c'est les prévisions qui est mauvaise
c'est tout parce qu'effectivement ne
peut pas comprendre
mais comme on arrive vu que tu es la
prospective épidémiologique avait été
fait dans les pays européens
continentaux
on s'était dit ça va être la même chose
en suède donc là c'était catastrophique
et finalement ça ne s'est pas produit
mais il est cet homme c'est un beau pari
c'est un grand paris c'est quand même
quelque chose de
je reconnais un extraordinaire courage à
cette des architectes de la même manière
les écoles primaires sont restées
ouvertes
je crois que les les universités ont
fermé parce que souvent sont loin du
domicile des étudiants mais mais on a
laissé les écoles ouvertes on a parié
sur le fait que les enfants n'avaient
pas transmettre le viol exactement ça
c'est un autre pari et qui va assez haut
puisque c'est juste que c'est pas
l'école primaire l'école primaire en ce
sens faites ce bal jusqu'au collège
inclut donc c'est jusqu'au lycée les
lycées étaient fermés mais jusqu'au
lycée s'était ouvert et là c'est
effectivement c'est un pari que jusqu'à
15 ans ne risquez rien et c'est c'est
vraiment pour pouvoir y vas comprendre
ça il faut vraiment voir le de l'aspect
l'aspect historique et anthropologique
de l'asthme de la suède et on peut pas
le comme on le fait d'habitude
uniquement le prendre sur une causalité
médias toyer donc je reviens sur les
histoires de l'économie et et du manque
comme vous venez de le dire finalement
il n'a pas eu de manque de lits dans les
hôpitaux
donc c'est pas ça qui est l'explication
alors c'est vrai que la suède était fort
dépourvu comme nous tous devant cette
épidémie pas forcément de masques y
avait pas de test
il y avait pas tant de lits de
réanimation que cela ils ont choisi le
de ne pas confiné aussi parce qu'il ne
voulait pas de détruire l'économie
ça a été dit un chaque fois que en gros
la craie la suède craignait davantage la
misère et ses conséquences comme
coronavirus là aussi ça a été une
différence avec les autres pays
notamment notre vous exagérez un petit
peu parce qu'on n'a pas utilisé ce terme
de misère en a pas c'est un mot très
fort en suédois lnd et et non on n'a pas
utilisé ce terme leur deuil on a dit
qu'il y avait une récession forte sans
doute si on confinait plus forte que si
on déconfit n'est pas m'aimer que si on
présomption de confiner pas mais mais
non cnrc c'est pas c'est pas l'argument
principal qui a été acceptée par les
suédois absolument pas là d'un clic
prestations que j'ai lu ce n'est pas
celui-là qui a été décisif du tout
c'était vraiment les premières et la
liberté aujourd'hui on l'a on la ressent
on souhaite on a vu parfois des photos
d'attroupement mai mais il semblerait
que il y en a très très peu on repasse
toujours les mêmes attroupement au fond
la liberté s'exerce aujourd'hui
réellement en suède oui oui mais dans le
peuple
le problème effectivement c'est qu'on
arrive dans la période la plus chaude de
la suède sur le plan des relations
sociales
c'est la période des grandes fêtes
d'ailleurs païenne de la nuit de
walpurgis le 30 août après après demain
30 avril et de même demain soir la nuit
de walpurgis dans le sud a su être très
largement cité valmoris mes sauts ashton
et puis vous avez l'ami de soba
rejoindre et puis vous avez pour les
études les étudiants de de fin de
parcours
les élèves de clown parcours le studite
l'examen du baccalauréat qui est une
très grande fête très grande fête pour
les jeunes avec énormément de
rassemblement et où donc c'est très dur
pour eux c'est très dur nous
contrairement à ce qu'on peut penser 7
jan ils ressentent un manque de liberté
dans l'est justement ce genre de fait
que collectives et n'a pas énormément
dans l'année mais celle là est celle ci
au printemps et c'est l'été en fête pour
la suède et c'est très dur au contraire
cette absence de possibilité de se
réunir
c'est un trait s'éteint c'est un mauvais
moment que l'on passe actuellement
vous lisez ce qui s'écrit aujourd'hui
sur le cas suédois
on a l'impression qu'il ya un gars qui
sue très curieux comme je le suis ce
serait quand même dingue si ça se
passait mieux chez eux qui n'ont pas
confiné que que chez nous qui avons
confiné mais aussi tous ceux qui veulent
que ça rate absolument est qui et qui
cherche dans les chiffres les moyens de
prouver que c'était la mauvaise
stratégie saas a sans aucun doute mais
pas beaucoup à l'intérieur de la suède y
en a il ya quelques semaines à quelques
uns mais mais c'est assez rare ya
effectivement il ya 23 chercheurs qui
ont fait et qui engendre qui ont annoncé
un manifeste de protestation avec une
pétition qui a suivi avec 2000 personnes
mais c'est pas beaucoup
en fait il n'y a pas eu de contestations
véritable et et d'une part et d'autre
part ils sont
je dois je crois le dire c'est difficile
mais ils sont très fiers de ce qu'ils
ont fait est de voir qu'ils sont en
train de réussir
il y avait bien toujours des et des
mauvais coucheurs qui disent maintenant
ça va à gaza va se gâter actuellement
d'ailleurs parce que ça redescend met en
avant on a peur d'une nouvelle vague
dans le cas des modules gens qui disent
être en sciences marines et mécanique
mais globalement je crois qu'ils sont
très fiers d'eux d'avoir choisi cette
voie qui les distinguent du reste de
l'europe voire du monde
ce qui est intéressant c'est que nous
nous en france sentance a considéré que
la la suède a pris des risques
considérables et qu'en fait elle a joué
à l'apprenti sorcier
or j'ai l'impression du point de vue
suédois c'est nous qui avons joué les
apprentis sorciers en confinant et entre
eux deux paralysant notre économie ce
qui ne s'était absolument cher et vu
dans l'histoire sans absolument savoir
ce que le ce que ça peut provoquer ne
saura que bientôt malheureusement c'est
peut-être nous les apprentis sorciers et
pas me oui oui mais eux ne nous accusent
pas d'être apprentis-sorciers mais c'est
nous qui nous accusons n'y a quand même
pas mal de voix qui s'élèvent
actuellement 1
ils disent même pourquoi on a fait ça
mais qu'est ce que ça peut tenir
comment pourquoi pourquoi ton paralyser
l'économie espoir pour quelque chose
je vais pas reprendre les mots de grippe
est maintenant quelque chose qui est
violent je veux pas mettre à mal je suis
pas médecin mais mais quelque chose qui
est violent d'enfin il ya eu d'éclats
pris il ya deux entrées set je vais pas
reporter de repartir la suite mais en
tout cas c'est ce et c'est nous qui nous
disons en voyant cet exemple là et aussi
l'exemple des autres pays scandinaves
que nous c'est nous qui sont apprentis
sorciers peut-être we say say say say
sur nos décisions qu'il faudrait
peut-être se poser des questions la
suède a laissé ses frontières ouvertes
tout comme la france d'ailleurs mais est
ce que ça veut dire qu'on peut aller on
souhaite aujourd'hui six mois sans aller
jusqu'à demander l'asile politique en
suède
est ce que est ce qu'ils me laisseront
rentrée si j'arrive à la frontière
suédoise ce qui est pas facile parce
qu'il faut passer par les voisins
absolument rien alors pour pour
stockholm et aucun problème c'est plutôt
au départ en france que vous l'aurez un
problème mais met à stockholm n'ai pas
de problème elle et des aéroports sont
ouverts à l'intérêt de la suède est le
seul problème qui peut y avoir c'est un
cas ce truc qu'il appelait report de
copenhague et de mal le sait il ya le
pont qui est là qu'ils soient qui joue
un sens fait c'est un don
c'est un aéroport qui est pour la suède
et pour le danemark tout autant et là on
a créé une fiche spéciale pour les gens
qui vont en suède
donc en fait il ya pas de procès pour
aller en semaine on vous pouvez aller
vous des conflits nés là-bas
écoutez non plus un peut en effet y
penser comment parce qu'en même temps
alors il ya une activité économique à
l'intérieur de la suède met à les couper
bien entendu de l'économie mondiale qui
elle est paralysée
vous pensez que la suède va en subir les
contrecoups fatalement oui bien sûr bien
sûr bien sûr non pas du tout
toute son économie et est fondée sur une
économie d'exportation et ces échanges
sont se font aussi bien avec l'europe
qu'avec le monde d'une manière à 80% son
économie est dépendante de ses échanges
l'a donc elle va en subir les
conséquences oui certainement
certainement c'est pour ça que justement
je pense que la raison économique
elle existe mais les secondaires du fait
que les autres ont aussi fermé leurs
frontières et fin de leurs échanges et
le temps limité leurs échanges de fermer
leurs frontières et donc toute façon on
n'en subira le contrecoup la suède a
longtemps été un symbole de la social
démocratie en europe de l'état
providence également est ce qu'il ya des
mesures sociales qui sont prises en
suède à l'égard de tous ceux qui ont dû
fermer parce qu'il y en a quand même qui
ont fermé leur leur activité mais aussi
pour l'avenir et en conséquence de cette
crise économique
mondiale qui frappera de toute façon la
suède elle aussi oui alors actuellement
les discussions sont en cours 1 c'est
pas c'est pas comme chez nous une route
tout de suite aux narcos naumoff on a
fermé énormément d'entreprises
évidemment il a fallu tout de suite
annoncé des mesures comme la ccc les
mesures restrictives ce sont surtout
pour les spectacles les cinémas les
théâtres et autres les musées donc c'est
en fait sur c'est sur ce plan là qu'il y
aura de nombreuses mesures de
compensation mais pour l'instant elles
sont pas encore vraiment un fichier ne
sont pas encore vraiment décidé
qu'est ce qui vous a attiré à la grave
vers la suède au départ pourquoi vous
êtes vous intéressé à la suède pourquoi
avez-vous aient été fermées partie de
vos études en sus elle vous savez et cd
cd hasard c'est les hasards du destin
c'est j'avais envie de pas de partir de
chez moi et puis j'ai connu quelqu'un
qui m'attirait la base vous savez à
l'époque
à l'époque on parle de liberté la
liberté dans ma jeunesse à l'époque les
libertés sur l'océan sur le plan de la
sexualité de la santé la sexualité était
bien supérieur en suède celui que nous
connaissions c'est vrai qu'il ya l'image
des suédoises plus libéré il ya eu un
certain nombre de filles je me souviens
des zozos le film de pascal thomas qui
montrait deux jeunes étudiants français
qui partaient en suède justement c'est
un peu un compatible avec l'image qu'on
en a aujourd'hui où les gens gardent
leur distance et est soi-disant ne
s'embrasse pas alors qu'à l'époque
c'était plutôt le contraire qui a tiré
les français là bas
oui oui c'était mais ces valeurs là vous
me lancer sur un sur une voie un peu
délicate dangereuse
c'est très très compliqué c'est très
compliqué parce qu'il ya la fois une
ouverture une une une compréhension des
besoins de l'autre sur le plan sensuel
et sexuel par exemple etc des besoins
d'hygiène puisque la gymnastique
suédoise c'est au début de mes années
1900 dont qu
et puis en même temps une certaine
pudibonderie une certain puritanisme qui
se marque dans les relations
par exemple je vais je vais je risque de
faire
de faire d'éclat avec mes amis suédois
mais des femmes suédoises ne vous
regarde pas je sais c'est en les femmes
ne regarde pas ne veulent pas être objet
du désir alors est-ce que ce tout récent
depuis le féminisme c'est un os que ses
plus anciens je crois que c'est plus
anciens mais je peux pas dire j'ai pas
trop de substances des carmes et donc
c'est un mélange très très étrange de
liberté d'une certaine liberté et en
même temps d'une résistance au contact
de l'autre parce qu'il me priver de ma
liberté
il prend le pouvoir sur moi je vous
remercie beaucoup à la gr portez vous
bien on va maintenant s'intéresser au
cas du portugal on se retrouve juste
après une pause
[Musique]
nous voilà de retour avec christina
semble haguenau qui enseigne l'économie
portugaise à la sorbonne et qui
travaille dans la succursale d'une
banque portugaise une bande d'état en
france vous êtes également membre du
parti de la gauche radicale portugaise
alors il faut dire qu'au portugal il ya
premier ministre socialiste le parti
socialiste au pouvoir et si j'ai bien
compris le bloco se positionne en
soutien extérieur au gouvernement un
cessna a tout à fait ça veut dire qu'il
s'est positionné un soutien au niveau
parlementaire pendant les quatre ans ont
des quatre années qui se sont écoulées
entre 2015 et 2019
par la suite il n'y a pas eu d'accord
parlementaire le parti socialiste n'a
pas eu la majorité absolue mais il s'est
passé des accords qu'il avait établie
avant avec les partis à sa gauche pour
pouvoir être gouvernement nous allons
voir donc là en l'occurrence le cas du
portugal est cité en exemple il faut
dire que par rapport à l'espagne sa
voisine qui a bien plus sévèrement
confiner le portugal compte dix fois
moins de cas confirmés est moins de 1000
décès comment vous l'expliquez vous moi
je dirais que le portugal a eu ma chance
si on peut parler de chance le portugal
les premiers cadres pour vie 19 au
portugal ont été détectés le 2 mars le
premier mort la première manche est
survenu le 14 mars
donc le portugal a été atteint par
l'épidémie
plus tard que les autres pays plus tard
que l'italie plus tard que la france
plus tard que l'espagne il a donc
bénéficié disons d'une période
d'observation des ongles il a eu le
temps de voir ce qui se passait ailleurs
et il a vu il a observé et l'attiré je
pense que les bonnes conclusions il a eu
les bonnes attitudes c'est à dire qu'il
a alti cité est effectivement avant la
serveuse
la première moyrand portugal l'état
d'urgence a été déclaré par le président
de la république approuvée par le
parlement et exécuté par le premier
ministre tout ça avant la survenance du
premier de la première mort donc le 14
mars
donc le portugal je pense que là il a eu
l'intelligence de voir ce qui s'est
passé ailleurs et d'apprendre et de
tirer les bonnes conclusions l'état
d'urgence c'était la première fois
depuis la révolution qui a mis fin à la
dictature donc ça a dû être un sacré
choc pour les pour les portugais du même
ordre que celui que nous avons connu en
france quand on nous a dit qu'on allait
confiné ça a été un très grand choc pour
le portugal parce que le portugal vont
cette indh c'est une jeune démocratie
nous avons fêté il ya quelques jours le
46ème anniversaire de la révolution des
oeillets le portugal c'était la
dictature la plus longue d'europe une
dictature qui a duré une dictature
fasciste qui a duré pendant 48 ans donc
parler de l'état d'urgence c'était
vraiment un choc très important d'autant
plus que cet état d'urgence il était
soumis au parlement elle était décrétée
par le président de la république il a
été soumis au parlement
le parlement avait la latitude de voter
pour ou contre mais ne pouvait modifier
aucune ces dispositions et parmi ces
dispositions il y avait au delà de
l'interdiction de la libre circulation
c'est normal puisque on voulait qu'il y
aller tranquillement
il y avait là vers diction du droit de
grève pour les professions pour les
métiers jugés indispensables essentiel à
la marche du pays et donc cette
interdiction du doigt
droit de grève c'est vrai que ça nous a
fait rappeler ça nous a ça nous a fait
rappeler les temps de la dictature ou le
droit de grève était tout simplement
interdit
il faut dire que le pourquoi on était
pourquoi j'étais personnellement il
était contre cette interdiction de 3
degrés parce que le droit de grève peut
être une façon pour les salariés pour
les travailleurs de protester contre le
manque de sécurité des entités
patronales si jamais il devait
travailler sans avoir la sécurité
nécessaire les équipements nécessaires
ils pouvaient manifester en faisant
grève et c'est d'ailleurs ce qui s'est
passé à france alors que c'était une
disposition assez dur mais ce que je
peux dire c'est que d'une façon générale
là il ya eu un consensus politique et
social très important au niveau de ceux
de certains cas d'urgence derrière il ya
la population elle-même qui le
demandaient elle demandait pourquoi
parce qu'elle voulait respect pour
l'écurie moi je peux dire qu'il ya eu
vraiment un consensus très très large
consensus au niveau politique et au
niveau social
alors on dit que les portugais sont
disciplinés on dit même qu'ils sont
obéissants alors je ne sais pas si c'est
parce qu'il ya eu une si longue
dictature mais ils se seraient confinés
de même au fond avant même l'état de
l'état d'urgence lé les portugais sont
restés chez eux certains se sont isolés
dans leur maison de campagne quand il en
avait une ils ont retiré leurs enfants
des écoles ils ont cessé de sortir le
soir
est ce que c'est bien ce qui s'est passé
oui c'est à dire ce qui s'est passé il
ya eu déjà des restrictions au niveau
local parce que il faut dire que là il
ya la direction générale de la santé
avait prérogatives pour pour ordonner et
le confinement de personnes malades
sur lesquels pèse une suspicion de
maladie et il ya même un district
conjugale celui dorval ou qui a été
proclamé un état de calamité publique
peu avant l'état l'état d'urgence mais
il y avait déjà l'interdiction par
exemple des visites aux prisons des
visites au départ et cetera donc il y
avait déjà certaines restrictions
avant nos rivaux mais je pense qu'il ya
plusieurs facteurs qui peuvent expliquer
là c'est que c'est fait que les
portugais sont obéissants les portugais
ont plutôt tendance à trouver 100 et je
pense que le poids de la dictature y est
pour beaucoup parce que la dictature
s'est pas seulement 48 ans qui sent bon
et elle reste dans la mémoire collective
et elle est transmise de génération en
génération et finalement 74 la fin de la
dictature c'est facile wax a donc même
dans la jeunesse vous trouvez des
réflexes de peur et se dira qu'ils ne
peuvent venir ce qui leur de l'héritage
en tant qu il peut venir que de ski lara
ce qui a été transmis aux nouvelles
générations par leurs parents et à ces
derniers par les parents je veux dire ça
ça se transmet de génération en
génération je ne pense pas que ça puisse
partir comme ça par grâce à un tour de
magie mais qui à ça il y à aussi moi
j'ai deux filles qui sont repartis
galles actuellement bien que parti
travailler là bas une autre qui est qui
est allé faire de la recherche que
chercheur invité à ce qu'elle me dit des
contacts et racé que les personnes
avaient peur qu'ils puissent arriver au
portugal la même chose qui est arrivée
qui arrivait en espagne en italie en
france et elle n'avait pas aussi que le
système national de santé puissent être
débordé mais je pense que le facteur le
plus important c'était la peur ce qu'on
voyait alors le portugal est un pays
vous savez le journal télévisé tous les
jours de la chaîne publique à 8 heures
ils durent une heure et il ya d'une
large classe qui est donnée à tout ce
qui se passe à l'étranger et donc tous
les soirs il y avait
pas seulement à 20h dans tous les
journaux mais il y avait le portrait
l'infographiste ce qui se passait au
niveau de la baby en italie en espagne
en france et cetera les portugais ont dû
ce qui se passait ils ont certainement
craint que la même chose survient chez
eux et donc ils se sont auto disciplinés
et se sont auto confiné même avant le
décret d'état d'urgence et après
évidemment beaucoup plus donc le pointu
le portugal au fond a eu la chance
d'être situé au sud ouest de l'europe et
que ce soit au fond si lui que cela
arrive en dernier puis aussi d'avoir une
seule frontière finalement avec
l'espagne oui ça sera certainement joué
mais je pense que ce qui a joué le plus
c'est que les vider n'y arrive plus
tardivement au portugal et et que le
portugal est prêt tout de suite des
mesures à la voix je vous ai parlé des
mesures je vous ai dit que l'état
d'urgence a été décrété
avant même la serveuse du premier mort
et l'état d'urgence était décrété donc
avant mais ce que je pense c'est que le
portugal a aussi pris d'autres
dispositions par exemple très tôt les
autorités sanitaires donc les hôpitaux
ont reçu des inscriptions pour conserver
un stock stratégique de 20% au niveau
des masques niveau de tout le matériel
dont qu'il devait faire des commandes en
ne tenant pas compte des 20% et le
portugal et la chance enfin c'est une
chance toute relative elle a eu la
chance d'être touché beaucoup plus tard
que les autres et même temps qu'il a
essayé de contenir l'épidémie
en même temps qu'il essaie de produire
la belgique il a commencé la chine
commençait à se relever et il a pu
passer des commandes des commandes
massives à la chine alors le portugal ce
qu'il a fait c'est que ces commandes
était accompagnée du paiement intégral
c'est à dire qu'on n'a pas à verser
d'acompte on n'a pas attendu la
livraison du matin
hier on a payé tout de suite en faisant
la commande
on l'aurait à l'intégralité que moi je
pense aussi qu'il était plus facile pour
avec un portugal qui est plus petit
qu'un 10 millions et demi à peine
d'habitants les commandes du candidat
sont forcément plus petit que les
commandes qui serait faite par la france
par l'espagne par l'italie et peut-être
que ça a favorisé aussi le fait qu'il
ait pu être livrées plus facilement ce
que je peux vous dire c'est qu'au niveau
test il était très limité au mois de
mars et pour moi d'avril ont commencé
déjà à tester beaucoup plus massivement
la population et ceci parce qu'à aider
aussi c'est évidemment la plupart du
matériel de protection a été emporté
mais ce qu'il faut dire aussi c'est très
tour des laboratoires au portugal où
vous commencez par exemple ce qui
concerne les tests de laboratoire ont
commencé à faire des tests
les laboratoires des universités le
laboratoire militaire
ils ont adapté n'avait pas exactement
les mêmes composants mais ils ont adapté
les composants qu'ils avaient et cela
est vrai aussi
et puis il ya des idées des usines
textiles qui volontairement parce que
finalement le gouvernement n'a pas fait
ce qu'ils pouvaient faire cette
réquisitionnés et surtout de contraindre
les entreprises à changer leurs aînés de
production mais volontairement il ya des
entreprises qui ont commencé à fabriquer
du matériel et tout ça fait donc moi je
pense que dans tout ça il y a je pense
que le portugal a été humble et car il a
été comme ça veut dire qu'il a appris
avec les autres et qu'il a anticipé et
je pense que la raison d'être d'une
situation qui est peut-être moi je
préfère ne pas m'avancer parce que on ne
sait pas comment ça comment ça va
évoluer mais je pense que c'est cette
capacité d'anticipation et cette
intelligence dans servent à 100 ce qui
se passait chez les autres qui a fait en
sorte que le portugal puisse contenir
davantage l'épidémie évidemment qu'il a
eu il a bénéficié du fait qu'il a été
qu'elle était dans la ligne à
erling comme vous dites au sud-est de
l'europe il a été le dernier pays à être
touchés christine vous l'avais dit il ya
10 millions d'habitants portugal mais il
ya 5 millions de portugais qui vivent à
l'extérieur du portugal vous en faites
partie
c'étaient les pets les fêtes de pâques
qui ramène souvent beaucoup de portugais
au portugal est ce qu est ce qu ils sont
revenus quand même est-ce que des
mesures de quarantaine ont été prises
mais ne vendredi avant pâques c'est un
jour un jour inférieur religion en tout
cas c'est le vendredi saint et est donc
à partir de jeudi du jeudi du jeudi
jusqu'au lundi on habite tous les
aéroports ont été fermés donc il ya vaio
posséder des appels pour qu'il n'y a pas
de les immigrés portugais ne retourne
pas au portugal et je pense qu'ils ont
écouté aussi c'était très difficile
parce que la fête de pâques est quand
même une fête très importante au
portugal beaucoup plus qu'annulé la
france sur l'impression est que bon les
immigrés ont toujours des membres de la
famille au portugal et donc c'est très
difficile mais je crois qu'il ya une
compréhension globale de la situation
alors il n'y avait pas de nécessité de
remplir des attestations comme ici en
france pour pouvoir sortir on ne pouvait
sortir librement
au portugal on n'était pas confinée de
façon aussi strictes que les espagnols
les espagnols les enfants de moins de 15
ans n'ont pas ne pouvait pas sortir du
tout on a dit donc les portugais
s'étaient auto discipline est néanmoins
il y avait l'armée il y avait la police
est ce qu'on verbalise est les gens qui
ne respectaient pas le confinement
comment ça s'est passé
ashley pas beaucoup entendu parler de
verbalisation des sanctions mais je sais
que avant même que l'état d'urgence a
été décrété par le président par un
public l'autorité
la direction générale de la santé avait
le
ward confiner les gens affectés ou les
gens sur lesquels il faisait une
suspicion d'infection et la
désobéissance à 7 à 7 à cette règle ne
pouvait être passible de cinq ans de
prison
donc il y a quand même des sanctions qui
je ne pense pas franchement je ne pense
pas qu'on ait beaucoup qu'on ait eu à
appliquer beaucoup de sanctions
aujourd'hui c'est un pays qui est plutôt
plus que les autres même si ça lui coûte
cher parce que ça coûte cher le test oui
ça qu ils testent plus que les autres
alors je peux vous dire que le portugal
était j'ai vu les statistiques pour
dimanche dernier au 27 à 27 avril
c'était donc lundi dernier le portugal
testait il était dans la moyenne des
pays dans ces lieux il était parmi les
15 pays au monde qui détiennent plus au
monde alan gross et diakité scène plus
et il était parmi les sept premiers pays
si l'on veut si l'on tient compte
uniquement des pays qui ont plus d'un
million d'habitants donc c'est vrai que
le portugal ne s'est pas encore
massivement parce qu'il faudrait tester
tout le monde on en est pas encore là
mais c'est vrai que le portugal a cure
et la rue parce qu'il a pu anticiper les
commandes et parce qu'il a eu la chance
si vous voulez d'être le dernier pays
touchés et de pouvoir avait un ton qu'il
essayait de contenir la maladie qu'il
essayait de ne pas obtenir les chaînes
de transmission communautaire la chine
commençaient à s'élever lâché commencé à
se réconcilier et donc il a fait passer
ses commandes
alors il ya eu d'un syndrome de mesures
économiques et sociales qui ont été
prises par le gouvernement
là et en particulier d'indemniser à 60%
de leur salaire c'est moins qu'en france
les les travailleurs qui ne pouvait plus
travailler
néanmoins il ya aussi beaucoup de
travailleurs comme on dit informel au
portugal alors que ce soit parce qu'ils
travaillent au noir on parce qu'ils ont
des emplois temporaires comment ça s'est
passé pour eux il y avait une façon
générale pour résumer il ya eu des
mesures comme été prise c'est le chômage
ce qu'on appelle ici le chômage partiel
donc les entreprises qui ne licencient
et pas parce qu'il y avait interdiction
de licencier les salariés
donc les entreprises que les listes qui
ne licenciez pas pendant une période
allant allant jusqu'à six mois après la
demande de chômage partiel elles
bénéficier du chômage partiel
tous les travailleurs étaient tous les
tous les salariés pouvaient en
bénéficier
qu'ils aient des contrats à durée
indéterminée ou à durée déterminée par
contre c'est vrai qu'il y avait il ya un
grand problème d'eau portugais avec le
travail précaire et le travail informel
nous avons beaucoup de monde qui
travaille dans dans le secteur du
tourisme par exemple la restauration
l'hôtellerie
nous avons les personnes qui s'occupent
de personnes dépendantes âgées et celles
qui n'ont pas de contrat qui travaillent
sans contrat et donc ces personnes là
sont tout simplement sans rien et il ya
aussi une autre une autre catégorie de
salariés qui a beaucoup super avec cette
situation ce sont les salariés qui sont
fournis qui travaillent dans des
entreprises mais qui n'ont pas de lien
avec 7,1 troupes et c'est à dire qu'ils
sont fournis aux entreprises par les
entreprises de travail temporaire
ils ont un lien de salariat avec les
entreprises de travail temporaire mais
pas avec les entreprises dans lesquelles
ils travaillent et donc ces entreprises
ont abdiqué de ses salariés et ils ont
été licenciés par les entreprises de
travail temporaire
donc voilà autant de personnes qui vont
grossir les les filières du chômage et
c'est vraiment un gros problème savez
une pandémie on dit que ce virus est
démocratique et n'avait pas tellement
elle ne douche pas les mêmes personnes
ou à l'intérieur du memri on sait bien
que ya plus de programmer nation à saint
denis et que les la population noire des
états unis et vous plus touchés de
l'autre et il ya eu et il n'est pas
aussi démocratique parce que au niveau
des pays dans la vulgarité ça veut dire
qui fait beaucoup plus de dégâts dans
les pays qui sont dus pauvres dans les
pays périphériques dans les pays de la
brd de la périphérie de l'europe comme
c'est le cas du portugal alors le
portugal vous savez le portugal a
souffert du fait que c'est un pays de la
périphérie avec des productions à faible
valeur ajoutée très dépendant de
l'extérieur très dépendante du tourisme
c'est un pays qui a eu qui a souffert
énormément de cette intervention
après assistance financière si la houle
après kaka eu lieu entre 2011 et 2015 et
qui a obligé à des réformes dites
structurelles très importante qui
affaiblit les services publics qui ont
affaibli le service national de santé et
qui ont surtout énormément précarisés le
travail que le code du travail portugais
a été complètement démantelée et malgré
le gouvernement qui est venu par la
suite avec un soutien de la gauche de la
gauche
c'était autre chose n'a pas du tout été
renversés malgré les appels constants
des partis à la gauche du parti
socialiste c'était autre chose n'a pas
changé donc le portugal est un pays
caractérisé
elle part par un travail par du travail
précaire et sans droit est donc un pays
comme ça va forcément être davantage
touchées que d'autres pays par les
conséquences économiques de l'apparition
de lemieux portugal compte aussi des
immigrés notamment des immigrés
brésilien je crois que le gouvernement
les a régularisé tous temporairement
afin qu'ils bénéficient de la même
protection
que les travailleurs portugais je dirais
c'était essentiel même temps c'est vrai
parce que c'est pas fait ailleurs donc
je pense que c'est une musique très
important du gouvernement portugais
1 parce que quand il ya une épidémie en
touche tout le monde et les choses les
sans-papiers et clandestins les sans
papiers j'aime pas mais aucun destin
parce que je trouve que personne avec
l'investisseur sur la terre elle nous a
pas elle appartient à tout le monde s
est fait que ça touche sa touche au thon
ou même plus qui n'ont pas semblé sans
papiers évidemment que l'évêque de la
raison le portugal l'ars a permis de
bénéficier de toute une série de deux
services publics notamment des minimums
sociaux des minimum d'insertion de tout
ça et surtout du service d'un sénat de
santé et moi je pense que c'est quelque
chose qui est fondamental non seulement
par rapport pour travailler sans papiers
mais par rapport à la population
générale je ne pouvais pas avoir d'effet
des foyers d'infection dans un pays je
regrette que cette régularisation ne
puisse pas aller au delà de la pandémie
parce que j'ai trouvé ce serait ce
serait tout à fait juste de régulariser
les personnes qui travaillent dans un
pays où est il ce serait tout à fait
normal de les régulariser
par contre nous avons beaucoup de
problèmes avec les personnes vous voyez
qui ne traitant pas étranger toutes les
dépenses sans papiers vivent dans des
conditions terribles et je me réfère
notamment à bétheny gitane
nous avons beaucoup de gitans au
portugal qui ont été du coup avec les
mesures de l'état d'urgence ont été
empêchés de vaquer à leurs activités
la vente à bulle at war les foires les
marchés et donc ils ont réussi sont dans
des situations de détresse très
importante et si on se réfère au
logement
évidemment que il ya beaucoup de
problèmes au niveau de l'habitat on
essaye
pour le portugal elle pas nous mais le
portugal essaye de les suivre
des associations mais c'est une
situation très difficile
le déconfinement va commencer la semaine
prochaine au portugal
alors on sait que l'économie une bonne
partie de l'économie portugaise dépend
du tourisme aujourd'hui ça semble très
anormal pour les portugais qui est si
peu d'animation si peu de langues
étrangères qui soit parler et à lisbonne
comme ailleurs est ce que vous imaginez
qu'on va pouvoir retourner au portugal
cet été nous les français par exemple
est-ce que les plages seront libres
d'accès le premier ministre avait l'air
d'en douter
écoutez on a déjà une répercussion de 40
% de perte sur le tourisme je ne sais
pas comment ça va se passer à la fin de
l'année ce que je voulais vous dire
arrêtez ce que je voudrais vous dire
c'est que ledit continue on ne va pas
voir comme ça lieu de façon magique
il est très probable que la levée de
l'état d'urgence soit accompagné d'un
décret de calamité publique qui lui est
même rare du premier ministre sans
passer par le parlement
il est malheureux du premier ministre
mais il engage la responsabilité et je
pense qu'on ne va pas du tout passé est
un plus
et hier encore le premier ministre
disait que avant de procéder au
dépouillement
il allait à la retraite à la fin de
l'état d'urgence mais hier il allait
consulter les épidémiologistes et et ce
serait conditionné à la vie des
épidémiologistes nulle part et d'autre
part à la halle abondance sur le marché
de masques et de matériel de production
n'a pas parlé l'existence d'une année
l'abondance donc si ces deux facteurs ne
sont pas réunies il y aura pas d
confinement je pense que quand même le
portugal est très pressé de commencer
l'activité économique que ça pèse
lourdement sur son économie
maintenant je ne sais pas comment ça va
se passer nous ne savons pas je pense
qu'on est vraiment dans un monde inconnu
on ne connaît pas ce lien
je ne sais pas s'il va y avoir un
médicament ne sais pas du tout comment
ça va se passer s'il va y avoir une
deuxième vague dans un autre pays
on ne sait pas ce que je pense c'est que
le portugal a très envie de de d'ouvrir
sur l'activité touristique mais je pense
qu'il prendra des messieurs et j'ai déjà
entendu on a déjà annoncé que la
fréquentation des plages ce ne serait
pas même si le tourisme était ouvert et
permis la fréquentation des plages ne
serait pas identiques il y aurait des
distances à respecter et cetera contre
je pense que même pendant une période le
portugal ne va pas si vous pouviez
perdre tous les bénéfices qu'il a réussi
à cumuler deux par cette politique de
prudence
dernière question christina nous reste
deux minutes
est ce que est ce que qu'est ce que vous
aimez l'idée c'était que de myst quelle
crise risque d'affronter le portugal une
crise de l'euro et elle était à redouter
dans les pays du sud moi je pense que
c'est à rebooter labidi sud et notamment
france pierre michelin pied dans le
maintien d'un sud
parce que bon l'europe elle montre
encore une fois elle avait déjà montré
lors de la crise dans la zone euro
qu'elle a abandonné les pays à 100 ça
c'étaient les champs pour soi et est là
il le montre elle montre également parce
que d'envoyer les balles de ping pong
entre les regroupe le conseil de
l'europe la commission européenne etc
d'erreur quand vous voyez que les
ministres des finances des 27 euros au
terme d'une réunion de l'eurogroupe se
sont levés et ont applaudi parce qu'on
avait réussi à avoir un plan de 140
millions de milliards d'euros qui est
pratiquement composée de dette
quand vous voyez que la commission
européenne a parlé d'un montant de ces
pas encore si c'est 1 5 milliard mais
qui va être constituée essentiellement
de der vous vous dites qu'il n'ya pas de
solidarité
l'europe fonctionne comme le père
fouettard qui vient vous dire que vous
avez dépassé le déficit et vous avez
dépassé la dette
le critère du déficit mais il n'y a pas
du tout solidarité et moi ce que je
pense c'est que les pays du sud si ça
continue comme ça les pays du sud vont
être abandonnés à leur sort et on a déjà
remarqué par exemple agences de notation
fitch a déjà changé la perspective du
portugal perspective de la dette
souveraine portugaise de positive à
stable
est ce qu'on a remarqué dans les
derniers jours c'est que tous les taux
d'intérêt des dettes souveraines sur le
marché sur les marchés financiers
l'italie de l'espagne du portugal et
même de la france ont commencé à
augmenter
donc ça ça annonce ça c'est le prix but
peut-être d'une nouvelle crise de la
zone euro d'une répétition ce qui est
passé ce qui s'est passé en 2012 mais
très vite répétition un plus large
échelle et notamment parce qu'il ya des
bornes dont cette banque centrale
européenne qui ne financent pas
directement les états contrairement à
d'affaires contrairement à la banque de
chine
contrairement maintenant même à la
banque d'angleterre la banque centrale
européenne ne finance pas les états dont
il va y avoir des besoins de financement
tellement important après cette pandémie
que les états vont être obligés de ceux
de se tourner vers comme si lancé auprès
des marchés financiers puisque la banque
centrale européenne ne finance pas elle
finance les bons mais elle ne finance
pas les états et que dans ces marchés
financiers vont pouvoir spéculer sur les
dettes et des demandes et des taux
d'intérêt beaucoup plus important donc
je pense qu'elle a raison si les choses
continuent d'être ce qu'elles sont
maintenant c'est l'europe continue
d'être ce qu'elle est maintenant nous
marchons à pas sûrs et rapide dérive
nouvelle crise de la zone
merci christina merci de nous avoir
suivis et rendez vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]
je